what's your reaction to the results that
we've seen
in many ways they're disappointing
results although
we did have very good results in london
and in wales
and in manchester so it's not a uniform
picture but
certainly some results were
disappointing
and it was very distressing to lose
harley paul
um it's interesting that you pick out
the three areas
london wales manchester where you think
labour did better
uh places where labour has a different
figurehead shall we say to the national
leadership in andy burnham mark drayford
and sadiq khan do you think that this
perhaps suggests that it is a leadership
problem
i think it's a strategy problem when
kirsten was first selected as leader
he talked about unifying the party and
he talked about not
over steering away from the policies
under jeremy corbyn
he needs to go back to that way of
thinking
i think sacking and urana for instance
is not a
unifying thing to do i think we need to
be
building on the policies in the 2019
manifesto
many of which are forward-thinking and
popular we need to get the strategy
right
you're talking about going back to the
policies or building on the policies
from the 2019 manifesto
some people listening to that might
think that is quite a staggering
um thing to say you know that was your
worst result since 1935 you lost 59
seats isn't that a manifesto that failed
it was a manifesto that taking the
policies
individually was very popular there's no
doubt
that the party leadership came under
fantastic media attack
but the actual policies were popular
the policies might have been popular
individually but as a whole they weren't
popular were they they led to your
worst defeat since 1935.
they polled well of course we had a
terrible defeat you don't need to
you don't need to remind me that it was
a terrible defeat
but you know extraordinary media attack
on the party and on our leader at that
time so we
now have a chance to regroup
to unify and put forward
those popular policies um just
i've spoken to peter bundelson over the
last few days he of course the former
paul mp you were talking earlier about
the disappointing result in the harlem
pool
he says jeremy corbyn is still casting a
dark cloud
he's largely responsible for some of the
losses that we've seen do you accept
that
long long corbin if you like is
affecting labour's chances
still well
we won hartlepool twice under jeremy
corbyn's leadership
and importantly with a bigger proportion
of the vote i mean you can't say that
jeremy is responsible for the hartley
pool result
the disaffection in post-industrial
britain long predates jeremy's
leadership and we have to look at the
roots of it
let's talk a little bit about kierstarma
and what he needs to do in your view
going forward you talked a bit about
policy and do you think that
and there is a wider strategy issue that
kia starman needs to do
talking a bit more about his vision john
mcdonnell for example saying that some
of those candidates were sent out naked
with no vision
no policies is that something that you
would agree with
i think that kiss darman is to go back
to what he said when he was elected
as leader and he wants to build yes
on some of the policies which we were
talking about in 2019
it is important that candid candidates
can talk about the labor party's vision
and talk about our policies
is it right that angela rainer should
lose her job as party champ
i said earlier i think it's baffling why
he sacked
angela rayna she didn't take any of the
big decisions around hartlepool
and we've not heard anywhere in the
country people
saying they didn't vote labour because
of angela rayna
what do you think it um says about
kirsten's leadership
if the first thing that he does is to
reach out and sac angela rainer who of
course is a
you know working class woman she she's
from the north
some people would say that she's the
kind of person that you need to
reconnect in some of the areas that you
lost
i think it's puzzling to sac
angela raina and it really is unfair
to have her take
i think we have uh lost the line there
to diane
abbott oh you're back good news uh
excellent um is the party too london
centric i know you're a london mp
yourself of course so it might be a bit
of a difficult question to answer um but
there has been criticism
for the current labour party for being
too metropolitan
uh too london-centric not reaching out
to the towns and
the more traditional areas of the united
kingdom that labour's traditionally done
well in
i i don't accept that at all
i'm a east london mp i'm speaking to you
from east london
and we have as much child poverty as
anywhere else in the country we have
very large numbers of blue collar
workers i think it's
in many ways an artificial distinction
between so-called london elites and the
rest of the country
what we need to do is bring together
hackney
and hartley pool in policies which
speak to the issues that both
types of labour supporter have in common
do you think this is existential for
labor it is extraordinary when you look
at some of the
results for example you know losing
hartlepool for the first time since it
was
created losing the majority on durham
council for the first time in a hundred
years
for many people the 2019 election was
seen as rock bottom but if anything
labour's gone backwards
are you worried that labour with this
realignment may not be able to win power
again
not at all i'm old enough to remember in
the 80s eric hobbs boom
wrote a very widely circulated
article on the forward march of labor
halted and his thesis was that labour
was an existential crisis it wasn't true
then
and it's not true now we need to unify
we need to regroup and we need to
move forward should a reshuffle be on
the cards
well i mean you probably know as much as
i do people are talking about a
reshuffle
but i think generally it's a mistake to
focus on personalities
we need to get the strategy and the
policies right
i spoke just finally i spoke to andy
burnham yesterday who of course as you
said you know was re-elected as mayor of
greater manchester
increasing his uh vote share he said
that if in the future the distant future
of the labour party should need him
he's there they should give him a call
it is now the time to be dialing andy
burnham's number
i had it's not for me to dial andy
burnham's
number but it's interesting
that he's saying that he would pick up
the phone
to the party leadership